wissen sie welches thema ich in unserer
viel zu kurzen sommerpause so gar nicht
vermisst habe war zu einfach drechselt
richtig ja projekt selbstversenkung der
britischen inseln wieder mal eine irre
woche in london vor allem für boris
johnson der als neuer britischer
premierminister das königreich
terrorisiert das ist glaube ich nicht
übertrieben ja ja um mit aller gewalt
seinen harten braig cit am 31 oktober
durchzudrücken wollte er mal eben das
parlament in zwangsurlaub schicken also
ein nicht gewählter premier urlaub ein
gewähltes und haus das jetzt ein gesetz
beschlossen hat diese woche dass johnson
eigentlich zwingt bei der eu um einen
weiteren brechreiz aufschub zu bitten
können sie ausschließen dass sie nach
brüssel gehen und um einen späteren
brachse bitten fragte eine reporterin
ja das könne antwortet johnson er würde
lieber tot im graben liegen
vielleicht johnson verlangt
bedingungslosen gehorsam nennt kritiker
verräter und hat deswegen 21 tories aus
der fraktion geschmissen darunter den
enkel von winston churchill
vielleicht hat er den bogen da ein
bisschen überspannt denn wie sich
herausgestellt hat viele briten wollen
doch gar nicht in einer diktatur leben
entsprechen dünnen das nervenkostüm von
bier bizarre beleidigung richtung labour
chef er sei eine big girls raunte
johnson dem oppositionsführer entgegen
die bluse eines dicken mädchens
die bluse eines dicken mädchens klingt
wie ein lied von den flippers es ist
dieser typ hier schreckten nicht einmal
davor zurück die arme alte queen mit
reinzuziehen in seinem blöden
machtspiele
es kann doch alles nicht wahr sein
wirklich traurig trotzdem gab es diese
woche natürlich auch schöne momente wie
zum beispiel das gesicht von theresa may
nach johnsons erster parlament in der
lage hier haben sie gesehen und bin ich
je eine schadenfreude nachvollziehen
konnte dann diese boris johnson müssen
wir darauf achten gibt am liebsten denen
ja den exzentrischen clown ja um davon
abzulenken um davon abzulenken wie
brandgefährlich er in wirklichkeit ist
jetzt kriegt er also seinen neuwahlen
und behauptet weiter ganz kurz vor einem
tollen neuen deal mit brüssel zu sein
schade nur dass brüssel davon gar nichts
weiß oder frau merkel übrigens ein ganz
großer fan von johnsons humor wie uns
ihr gesicht verrät wie in der uk und die
musik die wir schaffen das
man sehe täglich wie sie denkt claude
die blöde blondine bäume kriegs herr
johnson hat keinen plan b zum harten
drechsel null plan und er verrät auch
kein wie das eigentlich gehen soll die
zollunion verlassen aber ohne
grenzkontrollen in irland nicht geht gut
das sind so langweilige detailfragen
sowas spielt in seinem wahlkampf keine
rolle
wir schalten live nach london zu tina
hausten die offenbar ein bisschen von
ihrer journalistischen neutralität
eingebüßt hat hessen
[Musik]
ich bin gern auf die seite von gesegelt
klar sieht der buches aus als sei der
versuch eines irren wissenschaftlers
donald trump zyklon auf tragische weise
schief gegangen aber in sachen
propaganda macht ihm keiner was vor
während sich diese woche alle über sein
diktator gehabe aufregen holte boris
eines wissen hund aus dem tierheim dar
und ist einen 15 wochen junge jack
wasser den johnson weil sich aufnimmt
er gibt es bereits ein haustier katar
larry noch ist nicht klar ob sich die
beiden vertragen
er hat kater larry nach zehn minuten tot
gebissen
boris johnson dieser entertainment gott
beweist in der modernen politik kannst
du dein leben lang lügen dass sich die
balken biegen
selbst pinocchio würde sagen das kannst
du so nicht bringen
hauptsache du bist nie langweilig ich
weiß nicht ab und zu mal fakten finde
ich der politik gar nicht so schlecht ja
weil sie alt sind
boris johnson hat schon als junger
journalist in brüssel bewusst die
wahrheit ist letztlich auch nur ein
unverbindlicher vorschlag schrieb
geschichten die nur sehr entfernt etwas
mit der wahrheit zu tun hatten
zum beispiel wie europa versucht
großbritannien standardgrößen für
kondome aufzuzwingen oder entschieden
habe dass schnecken fische seien daher
auch der alte witz kommt blinder im
fischladen und sagt hallo schnecken
ja na ja jedenfalls der abschied von den
fakten es nicht ganz neue möglichkeiten
noch im august hat johnson gesagt er
wird das parlament auf keinen fall in
zwangsurlaub schicken
während er daran gearbeitet hat das
parlament in zwangsurlaub zu schicken
was ist was ist denn daran toll das ist
total befreiend ja auch für uns
journalisten
früher musste ich alles recherchieren
was ich ihr lover und jetzt kann ich mir
einfach irgendetwas ausdenken was weiß
ich
skandal boris johnson lässt sich auf
kosten der britischen krankenkasse die
brüste vergrößern
oder boris johnson hat eine affäre mit
schwimmen stone und traurig in seiner
freizeit bricht boris johnson gerne
achtjährigen die beine
naja ich fange journalismus früher auch
besser
oliver ich höre gerade die bbc sendet
live aus dem garten von downing street
an boris johnsons hund gibt seine erste
pressekonferenz wechseln dafür ist die
leistung zu teuer
[Applaus]